hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk all about the wildlings
at this point in season four we haven't
seen a whole lot from them and the thins
are the only real new tribe or you know
group of wildlings that we've met so I'm
going to do is a breakdown of their
history as well as some of their more
notable tribes if you're finding me for
the first time I do Game of Thrones
bonus videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything also because
there's no new episode next week I'm
just gonna be doing a regular bonus
video so be sure to leave me suggestions
for what you guys want to talk about
also round seven of my weekly giveaway
will start whenever I post my episode 7
review tonight so let's talk some free
folk that's actually what they call
themselves you know like people who live
in America call themselves Americans the
term wildling is actually like a racial
slur that people in the south started to
use so wildling is actually a derogatory
term which is why I wouldn't recommend
using it in Egrets presence she actually
spent most of season 3 trying to dispel
Jon Snow's preconceived notions about
their culture but the funny thing is is
that the people north of the wall also
have a derogatory term for people south
of the wall they call them kneelers as
in they kneel to a king like Aegon the
conquerer so just because people in the
south are super racist against people in
the north doesn't mean that the people
in the north can't also be super racist
against people in the south there's just
a lot of racism going around in a Song
of Ice and Fire in general I like to
think Jon Snow was a pretty open-minded
guy but the other highborn people in the
Nights Watch like Janos Slynt are pretty
extra super racist the interesting thing
about the free folk is is that yes you
know they do share some common beliefs
but they're really a society made up of
a bunch of pockets of smaller groups
they're like a patchwork Society of
people all with our own communities
because life is so hard beyond the wall
those communities also tend to be pretty
insular which is why it was such a huge
deal whenever mance rayder United them
and not just them he also got the Giants
to come out and play
he's pretty charismatic but I think he
probably just showed them all a picture
of a white Walker and everyone
collectively crapped their pants and
started running for the wall but where
did the free fault society originate
from the oldest living inhabitants that
we know about in Westeros at least on
the continent are the children of the
force but they're a whole different race
of beings the oldest living human
inhabitants that we know about are the
first men and that goes back about
12,000 years it's totally possible there
were other humans in Westeros before
that but record-keeping didn't really
become a thing until the Andals came and
formed the Seven Kingdoms which was
thousands of years after that the thins
we met in Episode one those cannibals
claim to be the last of the first men
technically everyone in the Seven
Kingdoms you know south of the wall is a
descendant of the Andals not the first
men but there's a lot of interbreeding
so we can talk about that in a second
and as a quick side note the tents are
not actually part of the free folk
they're actually a whole nation to their
own with laws in a king the free folk
are more like a free-range group of
people like Craster just living without
real government or a single leader the
thins are like a fully formed
nation-state a pretty big one when you
look at the map right here so the free
folk kind of evolved from the first men
that had just always lived in the north
as well as people who migrated north
whenever the Andals invaded just because
they didn't want about to a king then
you always have a few people who are
just trying to escape the law or bailing
on the Nights Watch so whenever we first
met mance rayder's army in season 3 we
were seeing a bunch of different groups
of people including the Corps free folk
like the free range communities then
there were the Giants which are clearly
their own separate race and the thins
which are a completely different nation
of people the show is kind of combining
a lot of things just to make it easier
to digest but generally all you need to
know is is that free folk are different
from Finn's are different from Giants
the show made the fence cannibals - and
that's a small change from the books the
real cannibals inside the books were
another community called the ska goes
they just decided not to feature them on
the show
so right now Mance Rayder is called
king-beyond-the-wall because he united
all those different groups in races of
people he tries to downplay the term
King mostly because not bowing to a king
is one of their core beliefs but he's
not the first person to do that they've
actually been six people since the wall
was built that have United the people
north of the wall what happened was is a
single person or in one case two
brothers united everyone in the north to
try and get past the wall mostly to
invade the south which is kind of funny
because they're kind of ignoring one of
the core reasons why the wall was built
not to keep the free folk out but to bar
off the lands of always winter from the
south you can actually see that area on
the map right here so the wall is not
trying to keep people north of the wall
out it's just trying to keep this one
area barred off these other people who
lived over here near the Haunted Forest
and the other areas actually fought with
the children the forest and the other
first meant to end the last great battle
with the White Walkers so technically
they should be everyone's friends but
naturally then the wall was built in
hundreds and hundreds of years passed
and people totally forgot about the
White Walkers so they started to think
more about the wall is like a class
barrier and then that's when the term
wildling became a racial slur and
relations devolved to the point at which
we're seeing on the show right now
everyone is forgotten about the true
threat everyone except for Mance Rayder
who totally understands what's going on
with the white walkers and a few other
people on the show so let's talk
geography real quick there's a couple
main areas up north of the wall the most
densely populated areas are naturally in
fen and the Haunted Forest the further
north you go the colder it gets
and even the free folk have their limits
Craster's for example is the closest
village to the wall if you can call it a
village as of the events of episode 6
though that no longer exists back in
season 3 whenever Jon first met mance
and saw his army they were up here in
the Frostfangs so now we're starting to
catch up with the show so remember the
raiding party with Ygritte defends and
as well as tormund Giantsbane
are coming from the south side of the
wall as of episode 3 when they killed
these villagers right here they were
directly south of Castle black
so the Raiders are attacking from the
other side of the wall which is a huge
problem because there aren't really a
lot of defensive positions on the south
side of the wall there's actually a
really interesting story as to why that
is because it's Castle black so you
think Castle naturally be fortified but
it's not fortified from the south way
back after the night's king remember
this guy we saw in episode 4 turned into
a white Walker remember he was the 13th
Lord Commander of the Nights Watch once
he turned into a white Walker and
started enslaving the other Nights Watch
brothers he rebelled against the Seven
Kingdoms and turned the Nights Watch
into his own small little Kingdom for a
little while
as a result whenever he was defeated
laws were passed that said that the
Nights Watch could never build defenses
on the south side of the wall so that if
the Nights Watch ever went by
in the future they wouldn't be able to
sustain a fortified battle against the
Seven Kingdoms and as an unfortunate
consequence of that totally unintended
whenever the free folk attacked from the
south they'll have a much easier time
taking Castle black that's really what
we're getting ready to watch play out on
the next episode episode 7 so cross your
fingers that the rest of the brothers
listen to Jon Snow's counsel because
everyone but Sam and maybe some of the
new people in the Nights Watch seem
pretty ignorant so what I'm really
excited to see in this next episode is
what the Nights Watch does to try and
repel this invasion and remember it's
not mance rayder's army it's just a
raiding party the Raiders are trying to
open the gates by the time Mance's army
arrives at the other side of the wall so
you have a small force here poking at
the Nights Watch at their weak point and
this massive army on the other side
getting ready to flow through this
little area and they're all converging
on it at about the same time so this is
all happening at once be sure to send a
raven to your loved ones because it's
gonna get very very bloody tonight I'm
really interested to see if they do more
cannibal jokes but now it's your turn
let me know below in the comments what
are you hoping to see in tonight's
episode I think we're all kind of
crossing our fingers for an Egret you
know nothing Jon Snow moment she's
really pissed right now so tonight I'll
be posting my episode review after
episode 7s be sure to subscribe to get
it
I'll be posting that Q&A tomorrow like
normal and feel free to keep leaving me
suggestions for bonus videos you guys
have been giving me a lot of really fun
ideas lately so right now you can click
here to get that episode 7 video I'll
add the annotation as soon as I post it
and you can click here to get the Q&A
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys in a little bit high fives
you